during the battle of dynant warp made an
ellen and her 5 000 troops obliterate an
army of 25 000 soldiers from the breun
kingdom leaving cantigra amongst the
surviving soldiers ellen ultimately
captures tigra bringing him to her
bustling territory light merits after
dreaming of being ridiculed by zion
tigra is awakened by lim and meets ellen
ellen tells him if she doesn't receive
the ransom for his freedom in time he'd
officially be her property ellen
arranges tigra for a demonstration with
an inferior bow when an assassin
attempts to aim at ellen with a crossbow
she destroys the bolt using aerokinesis
tigra determining the limits of the bow
shoots the assassin in the foot allowing
ellen's colleague and bodyguard lim to
apprehend the assassin although the bow
was poorly made to humiliate tigra he
showed exceptional archery skills ellen
offers tigra to serve under her but
since he made a promise to protect his
home back in the territory alsace she
allows him to keep his nobility title as
tigra grows used to life at ellen's
primary territory his loyal attendant
bertrand arrives at night in the
imperial palace telling tigre that duke
felix is mobilizing troops towards his
lands duke felix dispatches his son zion
to destroy alsace as a sign of dominance
now that the bruin prince has been
killed duke's fortune teller gives zion
two dragons to be used as war beasts in
light merits tigre desperately tries to
get back to protect his homeland when
ellen stops him and asks him what chigra
alone could possibly do against 3 000
soldiers he asks her to let him borrow
her army greatly amused ellen accepts on
the condition that she will rule his
lands which tigra complies in alsace
tieger's maidita helps to evacuate the
citizens but decides to stay at tigara's
home while zion's force starts pillaging
the town zion decides to destroy the
mansion he attempts to molest the maid
only to be forced to retreat after being
interrupted by tigra and ellen when an
enemy archer tries to shoot tigra he
catches the arrow and shoots it back
destroying his bow in the process tita
gives tigra the black bow an heirloom of
his ancestors after his humiliating loss
zion and his army of 2 700 soldiers
clashed with ellen's army of 900
soldiers on the open plains with ellen
antigra leading the charge when our army
defeats zion's first battalion he sends
in his earth dragon which crushes
anything in its path ellen faces the
earth dragon alone while lim and one of
the generals lead cavalry men to
distract the enemy forces using the full
power of her viralt with her long sword
ellen slices the earth dragon in half
while lim leads their pursuers into a
series of traps zion's dismayed and
refuses to send the wyvern into battle
informed the ellen's army is equipped
with 2 000 reinforcements at his rear
zion starts to panic the reinforcements
consisted of a shadow army of only a
hundred men with two thousand horses
zion orders the second battalion to
retreat consequently allowing ellen's
army to slaughter them from behind when
zion attempts to flee on the wyvern
tigra's black bow speaks to him and
absorbs power from ellen's sword
allowing tigru to shoot down the wyvern
and zion ellen's armies celebrate their
victory over felix's army ellen is
summoned to silesia the capital city
leaving lim behind to help tigra in
silesia ellen explains to king victor
that she was hired by tigra to invade
the bruin kingdom to acquire peace in
alsace afterwards ellen starts a quarrel
with almatt's war maid and mila but
they're halted by another war maiden
when tigra and tita return from checking
on the citizens of alsace they're joined
by martias tigra's friend and ally tigre
convinced his other nobles to join his
cause including hughes and his son
gerald ellen tigra and lim discuss their
plans but are interrupted by the arrival
of miele they decide to reconvene in the
village of roderick and mila questions
tigra about his motives as they ride on
horseback along the way they're ambushed
by the seven chains assassins mila uses
her viralt a short spare using
cryokinesis to kill six of these
mercenaries however limbs bitten by a
snake prompting tigra to suck out the
venom tigra and ellen head towards
roderick to get medical attention after
lim recovers from a snake bite ellen
rewards tigra setting up a bath in a
private hot springs bath house with a
displeased miele the four of them then
toured the marketplace in roderick but
mila immediately returns to her snowy
homeland on the border of light merits
ellen orders lim to increase the border
patrol correctly predicting that mila
has mobilized her forces during the
battle ellen's army clashes with mila's
army but their battle ends in a
stalemate mila retrieves to the tatara
fortress a nearly impregnable citadel
and ellen's army settles in for a siege
disguising himself as a bear tigra
scouts for an alternative route to the
fortress before encountering mila she
shares tea with him as she expresses her
misgivings of being a war maiden after
following mila towards the fortress t
group reports back to ellen as ellen and
tigra then lead a raid of 100 men into
the mountains ellen uses her full power
to try to break through the rear gate
but fails when tigret saves ellen from
certain death the two combine their
powers to destroy the rear gate and lead
their men into the breach after
destroying the rear gate of the fortress
ellen jules miele however the jewel is
interrupted by the last member of the
seven chainz assassins only to be killed
by tigra milo realizes that tiga not
only was the bear hunter that she
previously met but also only wants to
protect his friends in gratitude for
tegra saving her life mila declares her
neutrality thus ending the battle on the
western border of the bruin kingdom
roland leader of the nevada knights and
wielder of the legendary sword receives
a royal order to kill tigra later the
alsace army and the light merits army
form an uneasy coalition which is named
the silver meteor storm sophie who was
sent as a diplomatic envoy arrives at
the army camp informing that bruin prime
minister pierre has charged tegra with
treason sophie tells ellen the
whereabouts of the remaining four war
maidens while tigra and hughes struggle
to retain the loyalty of their allies
the novara knights approach enrolled and
rejects all offers of parley during the
battle of orange the silver meteor storm
suffers heavy casualties tigra is
severely injured while saving ellen from
being attacked by roland sophie appears
and uses her viralt a priest staff using
photokinesis to repel oncoming nevada
knights then again to vanish once ellen
and tigra are safely away when martial
martials and his reinforcements arrive
the nevada knights stop their pursuit in
the army cap masha says that he was
unable to meet with king farron though
prime minister told martials that king
faron's health is precarious with
tigrette still unconscious ellen
promises to win the battle and sophie
volunteers to help her after waking up
segre is guided by the black bow and
accompanied by tita to a mysterious
temple belonging to the goddess of night
darkness and death when teachers
possessed tigra shoots tita in a test of
resolve for greater power he controls
this power so that the arrow doesn't
harm tita causing the temple to
disappear the silver meteor storm
diverts the planes into a bog easily
targeting the navarre knight after tegra
arrives at the battlefield despite
reopening his wounds he shoots roland
with his new power roland barely
survives and accepts defeat with half of
the nevada knights dead the battle comes
to an end roland leaves his sword in the
care of tigra ellen receives a letter
from legnica war made in alexandra who
asks for ellen's assistance in dealing
with an invasion meanwhile roland
arrives in nice the capital city of the
bruin kingdom only to be killed by duke
maximilian with a swarm of bees despite
this maximum informs felix that an army
of 20 000 men from the museum kingdom is
invading the bruin kingdom felix takes a
third of his troops to face the invaders
and sends the remainder to nice in order
to counter maximilian when tigre hears
of this invasion he decides to face the
invaders despite being outnumbered
tenfold eventually tigrette leads his
main force against the museum army
vanguard and kills the general allowing
tigre to free the slaves gerald informs
chigra that despite suffering few
casualties their supplies are starting
to run low and that the retreating muzi
nail army soldiers are joining an even
larger invading force which will number
40 000 in mere days tigre leads some of
his riders to meet the museum army
cavalry which is unexpectedly reinforced
by the arrival of mila and her army
meanwhile aaron is told by sasha that
lebu's war made in lisa is using an
incident during their joint campaign
against pirates as an excuse to invade
sasha also knows that her viral twin
daggers refused to leave her despite her
poor health in agnes tigret negotiates
terms with mila to ally her army with
the silver meteor storm gerald informs
tigra that a rescued girl reagan refuses
to eat so tigra convinces her to eat
during the battle the ellen sasha
coalition army faces against the
labour's army ellen eventually
overpowers lisa who calls off the fight
liza informs ellen that fennardie and
ganalon are ready to move and that tigra
is facing the invasion from the muzinel
army ellen accepts the terms of the
ceasefire and hurries to rejoin tegra
meanwhile meena proposes only one battle
to defeat the musenal army which is led
by the coreys the younger brother of the
king of muzinel while tigra and mila
prepare for battle during the battle the
museum army of 40 000 troops arrives at
the ormea hills where the silver meteor
storm has made a small stronghold on the
first hills kuray splits his army into
seven divisions tigra and mila lead an
ambush at the second hill against the
fifth and sixth divisions however tigra
and mila become surrounded when
attacking the seventh division
tigra and mila are reinforced when
allied knights arrive to aid the silver
meteor storm although the reinforcements
are now a total of five thousand men
another three thousand men led by hughes
also arrived forcing carrays to retreat
and regroup when word reaches curies
that the muzinel fleet left behind to
attack the bruin kingdom's southern
harbour was sunk by felix carreys
decides to withdraw and give his
personal congratulations to tegra via
envoy ellen and lim return to tigra and
mila causing yet another disagreement
between ellen and mila that night tigra
and ellen discussed the battle and
tigrette vows that he won't forget those
who died fighting for him the asteroid
war maiden valentina uses herverold a
grim reaper scythe using umbrokinesis to
witness tigra in his sleep the night
before the battle reagan was attacked by
assassins and was forced to fake her
death without any proof of her bloodline
she can only prove her birthright as
faron's daughter in the holy in
artichome meanwhile felix receives five
dragons and moves to intercept the
silver meteor storm in lutetsia ghanilan
anticipates the final battle between
tigra and then a deer then sets fire in
the capital city during the battle the
silver meteor storm of 20 000 clashes
with the then idea army of 24 000 with
their combined power ellen and mila slay
the three earth dragons but the fire
drake and the double-headed dragon are
armed with magical chains and remain
unscathed after the army is reorganized
tigra leads flanking maneuvers against
the enemy forces while the two war
maidens decide to slay the two remaining
dragons by themselves
after ellen wakes up t grit tells the
girls that their next course of action
is to head to artisan reagan explains
that there are three routes to the holy
grotto and they choose the second route
through the mosha temple taking a hidden
passageway under the temple into the
caverns tigre discovers that then a deer
and his men used another route as a
battle ensues then adir sends his second
in command stead to pursue tigra and
reagan while ellen faces then idea the
cavan begins to collapse and then idea
chooses to retreat however stead
continues to pursue tigre while ellen
and reagan flee tigra is saved by
bertrand at the cost of his life before
stead is crushed by falling rocks
trapped underground tegra rushes to
bertrand who speaks of how fortunate he
was to serve tegra before dying ellen
and reagan pushed back to arteshem where
ellen finds tigra is alive and bertrand
dead in a pit as the final battle with
fennadier approaches the leaders of the
silver meteor storm wonder if tigra will
be able to overcome the death of
bertrand a flashback reveals that tigre
used the black bow to shoot through the
bedrock and create the pit tigrett
recovers his metal when ellen tells him
that she felt pride when she began as a
simple mercenary they then talk about
building a trade route that will connect
their lands the prime minister visits
the army camp informing that farron was
repeatedly poisoned by gun ilon but has
regained his wits during the battle the
fight goes in favor of the silver meteor
storm since dead no longer commands the
thin idea army facing off against the 90
year tigrit draws a single arrow and
throws out his quiver after ellen brings
tegra back to his senses the nadia
charges at tigra who shoots him through
the forehead out of his saddle in nice
the popular celebrates the silver meteor
storm as heroes farron agrees to tigra's
terms for peace and recognizes reagan as
his heir he also honors tigre with the
title knight of the moonlight
traditionally given to the future king
of bruin a few days later farron dies
and reagan ascends to the throne tigra
and tita return to light merits and the
construction of the trade route begins
by springtime so this is it for today's
video if you like the video give it a
huge thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel for more videos farewell till
next time